il y aura des enfants de 4 ans chômage
en dessous de la barre du million selon
le ministre du travail pc ps la rogne et
la grogne
après françois mitterrand antenne 2
georges marchais ce soir à la porte de
versailles le président giscard
d'estaing aux artisans il faut davantage
d'entreprises individuelles pour une
société plus stable
là messieurs bonsoir il est une guerre
au monde dont on ne parle presque jamais
c'est pourtant aujourd'hui en ce début
60 18 la seule guerre ouverte sur la
planète
cela se passe en ethiopie il te pi et
confrontez vous le savez à deux
problèmes d'abord elle doit mater la
rébellion de sa promo provinces du nord
l'erythrée et puis elle doit dans le sud
combattre dans l'ogaden le voisin
somalien
je ne reviens pas sur l'importance de
l'aspect stratégique des choses dans
cette région si convoité de la corne de
l'afrique
l'ethiopie est massivement soutenu par
l'urss la somalie les par l'egypte et
par lire mais c'est le versant humain du
problème qui nous a ce soir sensibiliser
fait comprendre à quel niveau de haine
et de fanatisme
on est arrivé à addis abeba quand on se
met à donner les mitraillettes à les
enfants de 4 ans on imagine ce qui peut
arriver
ces enfants ou quatre en quatre ans
c'est l'âge de la révolution éthiopienne
embrigadés dans les comités de défense
de la révolution ses enfants d'ethiopie
sont devenus notamment des agents de la
terreur rouge qui a déjà fait vingt
mille morts en un an en terreur
révolutionnaire rougeoie crise et
pélissanne des hauts plateaux
le slogan est devenu aujourd'hui un mot
d'ordre officiel dans l'ethiopie en
guerre contre la somalie
chaque homme doit être un soldat mais à
l'heure où l'union soviétique livre ses
mig et ses blindés à l'armée éthiopienne
on se bat encore dans les campagnes avec
les lances du moyen-âge la bible de
s'appelle aujourd'hui marx engels et
lénine ou pied film l'impérialisme
américain et on glorifie l'amitié avec
cuba on dit que la révolution
éthiopienne est devenue folle que la
population est broyé dans une machine
infernale et que cent mille personnes
croupissent dans les prisons mais les
défenseurs du régime affirme que c'est
le prix qu'il faut payer pour sortir le
pays du moyen-âge et restaurer la
souveraineté nationale
je crois que ces images étaient
éloquentes
j'ajouterai j'en aurai terminé avec la
politique étrangère en rhodésie le
premier ministre les nationalistes
modérés sont parvenus à un accord sur la
création d'un parlement à majorité noire
et puis qu en italie il ya eu un nouvel
attentat ce matin le chef du personnel
d'alfa romeo amine ans a été blessé de
plusieurs balles aux jambes
c'est une technique d'admiration pour
les terroristes de tous bords poursuite
comme prévu en france de la polémique
sur les chiffres du chômage nous vous le
laissions entendre puisque les syndicats
dénoncent cette part avancé hier les
chiffres calédonie le ministère du
travail
alors ces chiffres les voici aujourd'hui
un million 121 mille demandeurs d'emploi
en données brutes
cela correspond en données corrigées à
ce qu'on appelle donc les données
corrigées en variations saisonnières
cela correspond un chiffre qui tournent
à peu près autour du million peut-être
un peu plus peut-être un peu moins car
vous le voyez les calculs ne sont pas
simples en tout état de cause cela fait
tout de même une nouvelle diminution du
chômage la cinquième en cinq mois
diminution contesté donc par les
syndicats l'insee chômage un mot simple
mais une réalité difficile à appréhender
les statistiques que publie chaque mois
le ministère du travail utilisent
d'ailleurs pas ce terme elle parle de
demandeurs d'emploi cela comprend les
travailleurs qui ont été licenciés ceux
qui ont donné leur démission
ce dont le contrat de travail est venu à
terme ainsi que les jeunes à la
recherche d'un premier emploi et bien
sûr les hommes et les femmes qui après
une période d'interruption souhaite
retrouver une activité
première difficulté parmi ces demandeurs
d'emploi certaines personnes ont déjà
retrouvé du travail
mais figurent encore sur les listes de
l' agence nationale pour l'emploi
à l'opposé des personnes réellement à la
recherche d'un emploi ne sont pas
comprises dans ces chiffres
il en est ainsi des jeunes en attente
d'incorporation et de ceux ayant réussi
un concours d'entrée dans la fonction
publique mais n'ayant pas encore reçu
leur affectation
de la même manière les licenciés de la
sidérurgie âgés de plus de cinquante six
ans et huit mois sont dispensés du
pointage allen
enfin les deux cent mille jeunes qui
sont en stage pratique ou en formation
n'apparaissent pas non plus dans les
statistiques officielles
et c'est ce que les syndicats cgt cfdt
des administrations concernées par
l'emploi reproche au gouvernement
peut-on reprocher à mes services qui
sont responsables des deniers publics de
dire à des demandeurs d'emploi vous
allez avoir des aides publiques
venez tous les quinze jours me dire si
vous êtes toujours à la recherche d'un
emploi s'ils ne viennent pas si ce
demandeur d'emploi ne vient pas et que
deux jours après il n'a pas donné de
justification
il est peut être considéré comme n'ayant
pas aidé et en plus demandeur d'emploi
et donc il doit être rayé oui mais cela
fausse la comparaison si vous ne
possédiez pas la même manière les mois
précédents mais tout c'est la deuxième
mesure dont la cgt accuse le
gouvernement de l'utiliser c'est la
ligne emploie les deux mesures ont été
annoncées en septembre mise en place
progressivement et par conséquent il
n'ya là actuellement rien de nouveau car
juste une garde la question ce million
de demandeurs d'emploi est ce que c'est
un million de chômeurs non ce n'est pas
un million de chômeurs c'est pour ça que
j'utilise toujours le mot demandeurs
d'emploi si je devais donner un chiffre
avec l'expérience que j'ai maintenant de
plus d'un an et demi c'est 700 milles
environ un accord cet après midi au
ministère l'industrie entre producteurs
et distributeurs d'articles de textile
philosophie cet accord reconquérir le
marché national sans pour autant faire
de protectionnisme quant au dollar voilà
qu'il recommence à s'affaiblir un peu
partout sur les places mondiales comme à
paris il reste cotée à 81 84 cela veut
dire que le franc lui non plus ne sait
pas très bien comportées aujourd'hui
déjeuner de travail à l'elysée le pré la
république avait invité 20 artisans pour
prendre le pouls d'une profession d'une
profession charnière le chef de l'état
l'avait fait avec des commerçants et des
industriels des pme auparavant et ceci
afin qu'il n'y ait pas d'intermédiaire
entre l'elysée et ce que l'on appelle un
petit peu communément les gens de la
base
mais le risque d'investir en a profité
pour exalter l'entreprise individuelle
ces artisans ils sont huit cent mille en
france et j'en paye eux et aller voir
on vivait l'un d'entre eux cordonnier
aux mureaux c'est à deux pas du marché
au coeur des mureaux commune ouvrière
des yvelines est située la cordonnerie
de maurice le boulot un d7000 cordonnier
de france sa femme régine reçoit les
clients dans la boutique située au rez
de chaussée de leur appartement ils ont
aujourd'hui trois employés dont mario
accidenté du bâtiment et charles
l'apprenti arrivé depuis 15 et le boulot
se sont mis à leur compte il y à 25 ans
avec du matériel d'occasion après s'est
adressé en vain à une société de crédit
maurice n'avait alors que sa feuille de
chez renault on m'a dit non votre venue
mais pas suffisant sur les parutions de
vous prêter de l'argent aux minimes au
maximum 500 500 mille francs à cette
époque là et de la semaine suffisent
même seulement le pape porte que vous
avez goûté combien ce matériel aux
années fastes place ça me faisait un
million deux cent mille ans et vous
l'avez finances et comment par crédit
directement par la maison et dans
quelles conditions vous avez emmené vos
employés se désengager principalement
parce que j'avais du travail et à leur
donner
et puis il faut et penser à la relève
aussi vous avez bénéficié de primes ou
d'exonération à l'heure actuelle non la
fin il tout moment je peux prime si vous
voulez j'ai une prime qui est prévu si
vous voulez pour ceux qui ont embauché
quelqu'un à partir du premier jeu le 1er
janvier 78 qui compensent ou les heures
qui sont passées au cours sorte de
s'établir en cfa mais pas des
générations l'exonération non parce que
on a bénéficié pour celui qui a embauché
quelqu'un jusqu'au 31 décembre mais à
l'heure actuelle toute façon c'est
terminé c'est même dommage que ce ne
soit pas prorogé si vous voulez prendre
plusieurs mois ou peut-être même l'année
si on ya combien de corps d'annie au
mieux à l'heure actuelle nous sommes
trois aux 30000 habitants environ 30 36
milles enfin je ne sais pas exactement
c'est assez non je pense pas je ne pense
pas les gens soient incités de plus en
plus à faire réparer dans les années qui
viennent je pense que ce sera ça sera
infernal pour faire ce métier à quelques
uns sont donc c'est un métier qui a de
l'avenir
alors ce sur rue les gens aujourd'hui
l'impression de payer trop cher leurs
chaussures ou déjà réparé aussi trop
chers ou trop cher que ça soit
chaussures autres mais si on compare les
prix ce qui existait en bonne qualité si
ou des andes en qualité égale l'heure
actuelle la chaussure devrait presque
valoir le double et la réparation à la
libération s'ensuivrait et les clients
il en bénéficieraient vous trouvez que
ce n'est pas assez payé leurs revenus si
vous n'aimez pas suffisant vu les
charges que nous avons qu'est ce qu'il
faudrait pour vous soyez un artisan tout
à fait heureux à
c'est une question qui est assez
difficile heureuse
déjà moi travailler vous vous dites
qu'il faut plus de travail oui mais si
on avait du personnel ont travaillé à
part peut-être moins à notre revenu égal
à beaucoup d'autres
aucune raison qu'on travaille plus que
quelqu'un d'autre donc vous êtes pour
accueillir davantage de jeunes bah oui
les jeunes ont besoin de travailler un
drôle de procès qui a commencé cet après
midi à paris celui que 4500 entreprises
des pmi ont intenté tout à la fois à la
direction et aux syndicats d'edf est ce
la suite de la grève du 1er décembre et
des coupures de courant qui l'avaient
suivi tout au long du mois oui c'est un
dossier extrêmement compliqué dont la
synthèse implique automatiquement des
raccourcis qui vont faire hurler les
puristes
alors disons simplement que la plainte
des pmi correspond et s'appuie
d'ailleurs dans l'opinion publique sur
une sorte de sentiment de ras-le-bol des
usagers devant les gênes occasionnées
par les grèves répétées de l'edf mais ce
procès se pourrait aussi bien
s'appliquer à air france ou sncf
alors avant d'ouvrir le procès sur le
fond et lettres bien comprendre ça les
petites et moyennes industries avec la
met aujourd'hui en référé une expertise
pour définir premièrement si l'edf n'est
pas véritablement en mesure d'assurer
une production normale avec les
non-grévistes jours de grève
deuxièmement si les grévistes font pas
exprès de faire baisser la production
pour donner plus d'effet à leur
mouvement et donc en fin de compte et
c'est important de pénaliser l'usagé qui
est en droit et en fait tout à fait
étranger au conflit en somme les pmi
veulent savoir par cette fameuse
expertise réclamée aujourd'hui si l'edf
est bien obligé de couper le courant les
jours de trêve alors que répond le dr et
bien l'edf repousse expertise de la même
façon que les syndicats en dix ans aux
pmi trois choses premièrement votre
demande est en réalité une action
politique à la veille des élections
deuxièmement il est parfaitement clair
que les grévistes de l'edf n'ont pas
pour but d'arrêter complètement la
production ce qui provoquerait des
catastrophes
l'objectif de leur grève et de diminuer
le potentiel de consommation c'est pour
ça qu'un certain nombre d'entre eux
restent aux commandes pour contrôler le
débit qui doit toujours demeurer au
dessus du seuil de sécurité
et troisièmement enfin l'edf les
syndicats disent cette action cette
demande dans en réalité de remettre en
cause à dire d'occulter l'exercice du
droit de grève dans le secteur public
alors en somme le procès maintenant on
va se faire entre deux phrases les pmi
d'un côté arrêté de prendre
j'ai comme otages et les syndicats ne
touchez pas aux droites c'est donc une
affaire à suivre
très attentive oui avec une réponse de
madame la présidente rodez de la
première chambre de paris donc le 27
février
et puis toujours dans ce dossier
judiciaire une réponse d'alain
peyrefitte à andrest braunschweig le
président l'union syndicale des
magistrats qui lui avait reproché sa
décision de le priver d'une promotion
dans l'ordre de la légion d'honneur
c'est faux répond garde des sceaux votre
promotion et bien proposé pour le mois
d'avril et je regrette que vous ayez
manqué d'esprit critique et de sang
froid
la politique maintenant et ce sont
encore des chiffres qui sont au centre
du débat du moment
le coût du programme socialiste contesté
tout à la fois par la majorité et
notamment par le premier ministre il y a
deux heures à peine nous en reparlons
tout à l'heure et puis aussi par le
parti communiste le ton entre les deux
principaux partenaires d'union de la
gauche et d'ailleurs des plus est grand
en ce moment malgré un appel de françois
mitterrand hier la carte sur table pour
que partenaires et adversaires accepte
je cite de traiter calmement et
sérieusement les sujets qui intéressent
les français j'en veux pour preuve que
deux accusations assez graves
d'aujourd'hui
claude estier qui dans l'unité estime
que tout se passe à nouveau comme s'il
paie c'est préférer en fin de compte
conserver raymond barre au pouvoir et
puis georges marchais sur france inter
ce matin qui estime lui que françois
mitterrand veut avoir les mains libres
pour appliquer une politique d'austérité
c'est vous dire l'importance de la
réunion qui vont avoir lieu dans
quelques minutes porte de versailles à
paris un meeting organisé par les
communistes le plus gros de la campagne
et sur place parce qu'ici à charnay
depuis deux heures déjà maintenant ici
des milliers d'hommes et de femmes sont
présents le parti communiste attend
entre 50000 et cent mille personnes pour
ce grand rassemblement communiste qui
doit être qui ait ce soir la
manifestation la plus importante du
parti communiste pendant la campagne
électorale
à 24 jours du premier tour des élections
le parti communiste veut donner à cette
manifestation à caractère exceptionnel
il faut montrer la force et le dynamisme
du parti dans cette femme déjà depuis
quelques heures les militants font
signer des adhésions et collecte pour la
souscription de 10 millions de francs
décidée par la campagne mais au-delà de
cette mobilisation militante
le discours que georges marchais doit
prononcer à 21h30 et très attendu bien
sûr compte tenu du contexte politique
actuel alors charles fiterman cette
grande manifestation communiste
intervient à un moment où la querelle
entre le parti socialiste et le parti
communiste n'a jamais été aussi durs
sociable alors parce que j'ai envie de
vous demander qu'on va donc s'arrêter
cette querelle est jusqu'où aller vous
allez écouter je ne comprends pas parce
que je veux dire que pour ce qui nous
concerne il n'y a de notre part aucun
coup bas aucune escalade aucun
manquement à l'honnêteté intellectuelle
tenez par exemple hier soir sur votre
antenne
j'entends françois mitterrand dire que
dans une revue que je dirige économie et
politique
on a critiqué les propositions chiffrées
du parti socialiste avant qu'elle soit
publiée
or c'est inexact cet article sérieux
portait sur le programme du parti
socialiste publié début janvier
alors il n'y a pas de notre part
agression c'est au contraire françois
mitterrand qui se livrent à des
accusations sans fondement et moi je me
demande que signifie cette sorte
d'engagement du parti socialiste dans ce
que j'appellerais une stratégie de la
tension c'est très sérieux
georges marchais pourtant critiqué ce
matin très sévèrement de plan socialiste
il l'a critiqué parce que nous en avons
fait une analyse et nous ne faisons que
dire la vérité sans aucune agressivité
ce sont des faits dont nous parlons
charles fiterman françois mitterrand à
cartes sur table hier à évoquer
l'hypothèse d'un échec de la gauche
et dans cette hypothèse il a dit que la
gauche après un échec connaîtrait une
période de lune rousse alors pour est ce
que c'est une lune rousse pour vous
aussi si la gauche gagne les élections
perdre les élections pardon ou autre
chose une lune de miel peut-être ben je
crois que ce propos confirment ce que je
viens de dire parce que qu'est-ce qu'il
veut dire françois mitterrand que le
parti socialiste pourrait abandonner la
stratégie de l'union choisir une autre
voie
c'est cela au fond cette façon parler de
lune rousse et bien nous en tout cas les
choses sont claires nous ne varieront
pas nous ne changerons pas de ligne je
dirais que le meeting de soir et toute
l'activité de notre parti se résume en
trois mots nous voulons l'union nous
voulons la victoire
nous voulons le changement voix bon
cessange pas tellement ne le font pas
c'est pas vraiment la lune de miel et
bien non pas sont même sur l'expression
de lune rousse et sur la question de
savoir s'il ya ou non des coups bas même
si on en reste à l'affirmation du
principe ou bien reconnaître qu'à trois
semaines des élections
la situation paraît quand même très dur
chacun fait ce que fait peser sur
l'autre finalement une accusation
fondamentale le parti communiste accuse
le parti socialiste de vouloir aller au
pouvoir pour faire une autre politique
que celle qui avait été décidée en
commun et le parti socialiste lui accuse
le parti communiste d'être prêt à
prendre seul la responsabilité
d'empêcher la gauche d'arrivée ensemble
au pouvoir et puis sur le plan de
stratégie les stratégies elle-même ou
s'ils sont très claires et très
différentes
pour le parti socialiste pas de
négociations ni sur leur la
réactualisation du programme commun ni
sur la composition du gouvernement avant
le deuxième tour la victoire de la
gauche et pour le parti communiste le
désistement réciproque suppose l'accord
sur une politique donc même si monsieur
mitterrand espérait hier soir que le
parti communiste change d'attitude
même si pour ce marché s'apprête à
lancer un nouvel appel à monsieur
mitterrand la situation paraît qu'un
bien bloqué de ce compromis
et puis faut dire que le ps reçoit
d'autres coups de boutoir je voulais dit
tout à l'heure
raymond barre qui attaque une nouvelle
fois le chiffrage de monsieur bart
répliquer aux déclarations de monsieur
françois mitterrand hier soir à notre
émission cartes sur table et dans sa
réplique il ya d'abord des chiffres le
premier ministre
passe au crible les mesures du programme
commun mesure par mesure rubrique par
rubrique
tout cela pour confirmer les chiffres
qu'il avait déjà avancé d'ailleurs
antenne 2 il ya quelques jours
au total les mesures annoncées par le
programme commun représenterait 157
milliards de francs en année pleine et
lesieu barre ajoute les 70 milliards de
francs que devront supporter les
entreprises du fait de hausses des
hausses massives de salaire total donc
227 milliards alors qu'hier soir
monsieur mitterrand avait ironisé sur ce
chiffre avait précisé que les impôts
nouveaux prévus par le ps serait 15
milliards mais le premier ministre ne
reste pas au chiffre de ces chiffres il
tire des conclusions politiques et cette
conclusion la conclusion principale est
celle ci les français ont le choix entre
deux projets économiques qui sont
cohérents
le premier projet dix premiers ministres
respectent l'économie de marché
l'initiative et la responsabilité
c'est le programme de loi le deuxième le
deuxième projet comporte une rupture
fondamentale avec l'organisation
habituelle de notre économie c'est le
programme du parti communiste et pour
monsieur bart monsieur mitterrand ne
choisit pas monsieur mitterrand ne
parvient pas à sortir de l'équipe mais
on l'a vu hier soir au cours de
l'émission être attaqué à la fois par
monsieur par accor monsieur marchait
cela finalement ne paraît pas tellement
déplaire à monsieur vite et bien vous
savez maintenant comment nous ferait
tombe toute cette campagne électorale et
vous le voyez nous étions autant que
faire se peut de donner la parole aux
uns et aux autres et de ne pas
introduire de jugement personnel
ce que vous ne savez pas en revanche et
vous allez savoir tout de suite c'est la
façon dont nous allons rendre compte des
résultats
les 12 et 19 mars dans une conférence de
presse ce matin les responsables
d'antenne 2 ont annoncé que nous serons
ce soir là jumelée avec europe 1 c'est
la raison pour laquelle vous voyez ici
etienne mougeotte nos deux soirées
seront donc commune et elles ont un
attrait supplémentaire
elles seront diffusées en direct de
l'hôtel de lassay c'est à dire de la
résidence du président de l'assemblée
nationale
et c'est pourquoi vous avez d'ailleurs
vu edgar faure voilà pour les faits jean
pierre elkabbach maintenant la
philosophie c'est d'abord le pourquoi de
l'endroit et coûté des milliers de
candidats se disputent les suffrages des
français pour avoir l'honneur de siéger
à l'assemblée nationale de défendre les
couleurs de leur parti et une certaine
idée de la france
cela semblait donc un lieu symbolique le
lieu idéal pour nous c'est ce qu'ont
très bien compris le président
car fort et le bureau de l'assemblée et
c'est donc un hommage logique que nous
rendons à l'ensemble et pourquoi europe
1 écoutez le succès de l'expérience
tentée l'an dernier à l'occasion des
élections municipales nous encourager à
renouveler l'accord des deux sociétés
pour ses soirées exceptionnelles c'est à
dire que nous allons unir les rédactions
les moyens les programmes aussi entre
20h et 23h pour la qualité et
l'efficacité de la présentation des
résultats des commentaires des réactions
ou des débats et pour qu'ils soient les
meilleurs possibles
le grand débat est en tout cas prévu à
21h15 avec les principaux dirigeants
politiques
mais dès 20h il y aura les estimations
fournies par la c2i honeywell bull le 12
mars pour le pourcentage en voie de
chaque famille politique vous savez
combien c'est important pour le deuxième
tour le résultat final
le 19 mars la composition de la nouvelle
assemblée nationale aura l'occasion d'en
reparler bien sûr et puis il faut dire
qu'il ya aussi deux autres innovations
ya le programme antenne 2 et d'europe 1
sera ce soir là encore une fois comment
elle sera ponctuée de divertissement de
qualité
c'est pourquoi nous avons demandé à
jacques chancel de choisir et de
présenter des séquences enregistrées qui
seront diffusées dès que le rythme de la
formation le permettra et ralentira
enfin pour la première fois je crois que
ça n'a jamais été tentée en france nous
allons associer à ces soirées des
téléspectateurs six d'entre eux de paris
et de province qui avait participé vous
en souvenez peut-être dossiers de
l'écran organisé par armand jammot sur
la vie politique et les partis vont
interroger avec nous les commentateurs
alain duhamel en tête et les
responsables politiques qui sont avec
nous dans la salle des fêtes de l'hôtel
de lassay mais encore une fois nous
aurons l'occasion d'y revenir
il faut ajouter que les 13 et 20 martyrs
a aussi un journal à la mi journée ce
qui n'est pas habituel la journal
exceptionnelle de 12h30 20h30 et un
exceptionnellement également un journal
à 20 heures qui durera 45 minutes la
ferme dont je vais vous parler est tout
de même assez extraordinaire mais je
crois qu'il faut pas la traiter à la
légère
l'ancienne infirmière en chef d'un
hospice de vieillards en belgique a été
cet après midi inculpé du meurtre de
trois vieillards la firme hier les
aurait piqué à l'insuline pour ne pas
qu'ils souffrent selon ses dires et
voilà qu'on se demande si rien n'a pas
tué d'autres
on va donc exhumer les corps d'une
dizaine d'autres malades morts l'année
dernière
dans cet hôpital il faut que je vous
dise maintenant le plus grave c'est que
cette infirmière est une religieuse
elle s'appelle sur gottfried a jusqu
alors une aide infiniment dévouée et
compétente mais depuis peu gravement
affaibli physiquement et mentalement il
ya une heure à peine une expédition guen
s'achever au gouffre de la pierre
saint-martin 8 spéléologues pyrénéens
vont remonter viennent de remonter après
avoir réalisé la plus longue traversée
souterraine 20 km dans le gouffre le
plus profond du monde c'est un peu le
ministre allant vers le gouffre de la
pierre saint martin près d'ars est dans
les pyrénées ce n'est pas l'everest
sommet en bas mais avec très 132 mètres
de dénivelé c'est le plus profond du
monde
l'intégrale c'est-à-dire l'aller-retour
fait aujourd'hui 25 kg outre la pierre
saint martin avec le vif jean bernard et
le gouffre berger la france possède les
trois qualités les plus profondes du
monde et par voie de conséquence sans
doute les meilleurs délais le groupe de
la spéléologie de tarbes qui est à
l'origine de cette tentative pratique la
pierre saint martin depuis 15 ans ces
spéléologues ont de nombreuses
découvertes à leur actif beaucoup
d'efforts à sion plus de 300 qualité et
de nombreux sauvetages le dernier en
date celui d'une équipe de tf1
motivation essentielle de cet exploit le
sport une manière de se mesurer et se
met entre parenthèses de la spéléologie
mondiale parce que le des prêts là tout
simplement
au delà du sport et de la mise en
pratique de nouveaux matériels autre
motivation faire connaître au public le
travail considérable réalisé sous terre
par les spéléo ah si l'étude d'un réseau
hydraulique permet de détecter
d'éventuelles pollutions il ya quelques
mois grâce au spéléologue les habitants
d'un petit village du doubs ont appris
que l'eau qu'ils consommaient n'était
autre que celle rejetée par eux quelques
kilomètres plus bas
et puis la spéléo avec peut-être lé
aventure sous marine c'est encore l'une
des rares disciplines où la découverte
est toujours possible comme cette grande
salle de la pierre saint martin la verna
on pourrait y mettre deux cathédrales
comme notre dame de paris
impression de débouchés dans la nuit
dans un autre monde aussi vaste duquel
je tenais une nuit fantastique avec les
petites veines dans les rochers donné
l'impression que c'était des nuages
il manquait que les étoiles pour
vraiment que je crois que que j'étais
dans la nuit à partir d'un but à l'autre
et en un seul ray de la pierre saint
martin pour les huit spéléo de tarbes
le rêve est presque devenu réalité après
4 jours et 3 nuits d'efforts un exploit
la mémoire d'autres spéléo qui ont
trouvé la mort dans ce but
en pratiquant leur sport favori bien
restons dans le domaine des exploits
sportifs car c'est une remarquable
performance qu'a réalisée cette nuit un
jeune boxeur de 24 ans leon spinks qui a
battu à las vegas le fameux mohamed ali
cassius clay si vous préférez l'a battu
aux points et lui a donc ravi la
couronne de champion du monde des poids
lourds casus clés à 36 ans alors est-ce
le début de la fin dans le voir sur ces
images
ça devait arriver un jour bien sûr en
france et fera tout de même que ceux-ci
s'interrompre à un règne de 80 ce qui
apparut curieux d'après ces images c'est
l'attitude de claix qui n'a pas toujours
donné l'impression de défendre ses
chances avec son talent habituel mais ce
n'est peut être qu'une impression vu
d'ici de faerie sert celui qui se dit
depuis longtemps le plus vont le plus
grand le plus fort
à 36 ans spinks 24 seulement ceci
explique en partie cela
c'est en 1964 que clay devenu champion
du monde pour la première fois vous en
souvenez peut-être en battant liston il
a détendu 22 fois sa couronne et avance
pin's seul frasier norton l'avait battue
la défaite de cette nuit annonce
peut-être la fin d'un règne mais on
n'est pas prêt d'oublier clay c'était un
personnage hors pair il ya eu tort
cependant le mésestimé son adversaire
qu'il avait réutilisé avant de son bac
en là dedans par dérision le castor en
raison de sa dentition puis avait du
football hier soir au 6 mai en france
tous les matchs n'ont pas pu être joué
notamment la rencontre phare nantes
monaco
du coup marseille a sauté sur l'occasion
pour s'installer en tête du championnat
cela lui a été d'autant plus facile que
le quatrième larron de tête nice a été
une nouvelle fois battu et sur son
terrain par paris saint germain
là aussi c'est peut-être le début de la
fin de la saison pour la grande équipe
de nice
pourtant nice aurait dû se méfier car le
paris saint germain c'est décidément une
équipe curieuse alors qu'ils se font
battre assez souvent chez eux au parc
des princes par des adversaires modestes
les parisiens sont souvent les auteurs
de grosses surprises hors de paris hier
soir à nice le psg est parvenu à marquer
deux buts en une demi heure après le but
de brisson voici celui du niçois syrie
contre son camp un comble de malchance
ou de maladresses comme vous voudrez
paris mènent ainsi 2 à 0 à la décharge
des niçois les absences de l'udc et de
guillou heureusement pour eux djokovic
est là et le yougoslave redonne quelques
illusions aux niçois en inscrivant un
but juste avant la mi temps les
parisiens reprennent le large grâce à
redon et ont le sentiment à dix minutes
de la fin d' avoir match gagné
ils ont raison car le deuxième but
denise allez le voir oeuvre si l'on peut
dire du parisien morin contre son camp
ne change rien à la faire paris a donc
gagné 3 à 2 ça va mal pour nice qui doit
encore rencontrer le psg samedi et
mercredi sept fois en coupe de france
deux occasions de faire oublier le faux
pas d'hier soir il y avait un quarter
cet après midi à vincennes résultats le
16 le 8 le 6 et le 2 et les rapports
voulait découvre à l'instant sur votre
écran et puis n'oubliez pas un grand
rendez vous sportif sur à 2 après demain
samedi france irlande en rugby bien sûr
pour le tournoi du pour le compte du
tournoi des cinq nations
mais pour l'instant vous voyez le
terrain du parc des princes est toujours
sous la neige
les pompiers de paris toute la journée
de demain vont essayer d'aspirer cette
neige est pour l'instant dans l'état
actuel des choses on n'envisage pas le
report du match l'a d'ailleurs beaucoup
neigé sur la france qui a entraîné le
blocage de la circulation dans la sarthe
dans leur devant le tunnel du mont blanc
et même à roissy où un avion s'est
embourbé dans la neige demain changement
de décor avec le redoux inondations et
avalanches sont à craindre surtout dans
la moitié sud du pays dans l'orgue qui
fera encore froid avec brouillard
verglas et chutes de neige
j'ajoute que j'apprends à l'instant que
deux arrestations ont été opérées dans
la sphère du hold up de corfou vous
souvenez l'été dernier
le hold up du club méditerranée de
corfou de l'arrestation donc deux
français arrêtés à palma de majorque
voilà cette édition est à présent
terminé merci de l'avoir suivi avec
toute la rédaction d'antenne 2 c'est
patrick low cost ou pas entre albanais
journal vers 23 heures
bonsoir à demain